rate of aftershocks from what we're
recording and from that we have about an
80% chance of at least one magnitude
five and about a 9% chance that
something larger than 6.4 could occur
over the next week that's just saying
this is a big sequence which shouldn't
be surprising anybody who's been
watching what's been going on for the
last two hours we also have locations on
some of them and that's what we were
trying to get up this this map here and
it's interesting it does look like we
might be seeing two different faults
okay yeah yeah if you would do that so
the the after the main shock was
actually located in the middle at the
intersection between those those two
strands and so we think the main fault
was rupturing down towards the southwest
which would have focused the energy
towards Ridgecrest but then there's also
a second fault that seems to have been
activated going up to the northwest I
get this area that's not completely
surprising look at those little black
lines in there there's a bunch of them
this is an area with a lot of little
folks that in a rather complex area
moving apart it does suggest that ridge
crest was particularly hard-hit we have
reports from California Office of
Emergency Services that they there are
there seem to be a couple of structure
fires going on in rich crest and they're
responding to them there is also a small
community called trona which is even
closer to the ruptures and it's on a dry
lakebed we do not have any communication
with them yet there would be a place
that potentially there's there
significant damage as I said we've seen
at least two faults involved this area
is characterized by robust sequences so
we expect to be seeing a lot of
earthquakes today and
some of them could be could be damaging
probably at least one more will be
damaging County just tweeted something
that suggested that they were
anticipating a quake in 15 minutes
that's between China there is nothing
that gives us the time of a particular
event now I'm going to tell you I think
there will be a magnitude five today I
did that on the day of Northridge and
when it happen people said you predicted
the earthquake and I said I predict rain
and collide - this is the same situation
when the probabilities are this high you
you know then you can say yes they'd
probably be a magnitude five today but
it's not the time of any particular
event
there's nothing if somebody's giving out
of time if a particular event they're
not basing it on science okay that's
probably what was really God about the
aftershocks you said we don't yet have
the geologists haven't yet gotten out so
we don't have a report yet on that oh
well that's true one place likes did you
just notice Q aftershocks showed up I
just saw the two extra red dots that
showed up here this type of yes
conjugate behavior is relatively common
back in 1987 we had a humanity sixes on
conjugant faults the Landers earthquake
with Big Bear there Big Bear was a
little more separated from it but was
the same type of conjugate feature the
way the stress works if I'm pushing in
this way I can move out here or I can
move out here and so those essentially
perpendicular we call it conjugate
faulting is a common feature and we will
just have to see we're only two hours
into this sequence we'll have to see how
it develops yeah
yeah so I can give an update about that
and there's maybe a little bit of
misunderstanding or missing
the system actually worked as designed
so in a work was sent out by the US
Geological Survey the app for the city
of La is set up with various thresholds
the first threshold is a magnitude 5
earthquake or greater in LA County it
will send out an alert this earthquake
was outside of LA County so it didn't
satisfy that condition the other
condition is intensity greater than for
the intensities in LA were 3 and lower
so the app performed as designed it's
just that the intensity levels were
below that threshold that it had been
set by the so the system actually worked
as designed it's something that we need
to look into though as to whether maybe
that threshold it should be lowered or
adjusting for the future and just to
reiterate though there was no that the
level of shaking within the City of LA
area was not damaged so so for example
if it had been 3 intensity 3 or then
people would have gotten notification to
expect shaking the I don't know the
exact wording on the app but there would
have been a significant number yeah 45
seconds before the shaking actually
arrived so the alert would have worked
beautifully in that sense but again the
shaking levels would not have been
damaging certainly it would have been
great you know to kind of know
does it have Sounders it just like a tax
right actually not sure the set high
enough it's never gone off on my
computer on my phone so I'm not
completely sure I think they may be
using something well they were going to
be using a chiming alert that's used in
Japan but there were I'm not sure which
one they ended up using you don't want
to start getting so many alerts that
people don't pay attention when they get
them right and this is something that's
actually been studied explain that
people didn't do that okay so just to
repeat the question was or the reason
why potentially that the alert level is
inside lower is so that you don't have a
large number of alerts with minimal
shaking and that is correct and this is
a subjective judgement and so in
designing the app you have to make a
decision on it there's actually been a
fair amount of research looking into
this and other places like Japan and
Mexico and there's some sense that
people don't mind getting an alert even
if the shaking is not that severe and
which would have been the case here if
it had been set to intensity 3 and so so
this is something that maybe we need to
you know again maybe needs to be looked
at tweaked on the system yes sorry so to
clarify because there's been some talk
about
there have been hundreds of likes for a
wild the website showed two magnitude
6.4 s so the way the system works is
there's a lot of us recording
earthquakes around the world especially
and we have a system that if somebody
else puts up an alert and you know
there's always the chance at the Great
Pasadena earthquake means that we aren't
giving out anything so you want to have
somebody else be able to say it if we're
not here and and so there's a system to
try and negotiate that there was a
warning we think it was from the tsunami
warning center actually and the timing
usually the system can recognize there
the same earthquake if one of the
systems gets the time a little off then
they look like different earthquakes and
the system of the automatic system
allows it to go in so for a short time
there were two alerts one from us one
from from the tsunami warning center and
when we recognized that it was there we
went in and cleaned it up yeah that was
not getting rid of an earthquake by the
way I've heard the conspiracy theorists
about that it's it's just that we clean
it up right and and just to clarify
additionally we had been just talking
about two faults and so forth
that's not we're not not until we get a
geologist on the ground yeah
occasionally there are reports about
faults that we do not know about we know
a lot of folks in this area I mean just
if you look again at the picture some
how this appears which just disappeared
on us the if we could maybe just reload
the page I would guess all right but
look up in that area there's lots of
little marks on the it's one of the
areas with the dense distribution of mat
faults so before I'm going to talk about
an unknown fault I need a geologist to
say how is this tube line up with the
ones we know about it is it relevant
that there are lots of us people I think
it's a psychological issue if it's an
unknown fault my god then we you know H
you know we didn't know it makes it
scarier the reality is we have a lot of
little faults that never get names
because they're too small until you get
an earthquake was this one particularly
strong for that area this earthquake is
the largest in the Little Lake area in
the last century but in general the
Owens Valley this sort of Co object
structures up there I've had a lot of
earthquakes like this
there was actually a seven and a half in
1872 that ran through it was usually
called the independents earthquake or
sometimes just the Owens Valley
earthquake mammoth historically has had
dozens of magnitude sixes so as a
geology I say that area largest
earthquake in 100 years does that make
it unusual no from geology we really
need to know we need to look at
millennia to say what standard we're
waiting for the picture to show up I
mean know take a picture and send it to
us ago look at there's the fault offset
it's there's a one level at which it's
simple the geologists in presume there
are fault offsets will probably be
mapping it in detail over the next month
we don't have enough money to send
helicopters is there a National Guard
does
yeah yeah no not the geologists look at
our budget sometime yeah yeah so there
are there they are on route and as soon
as we have information you know
regarding your fault offsets or anything
like that will provide it hopefully
within and since we don't have any
pictures in yet when you again sort of
illustrate what that's going to look
like what a seismologist we'd want to
take a photo of yeah well yeah so we're
speculating a little bit here in that we
don't you think we don't know yet if
this fault actually ruptured to the
ground surface and it's magnitude six
point four in California sometimes break
all the way to the ground surface and
sometimes don't so when somebody
actually have some definitive
information if it did break up to the
ground surface what we should see is
where two sides of the WHA or two sides
of the ground that were close together
have slid horizontally relative to each
other and there may be some vertical
displacements as well but given the
information that we have recorded the
seismographs it looks like the offset on
the fault if it as broken of the surface
will be that horizontal starts to the
motion how does that information help
well obviously if in terms of damage if
you have a pipeline or a structure that
straddles that fault and it moves
sideways but that could be very
devastating I don't know if that's the
case here again also in terms of the
ground shaking that was experienced in
the ridge crest area lucy was talking
before about how the earthquake started
off to the northeast and propagated to
the south west towards ridge crest with
this type of horizontal motion that can
actually be amplified again we until we
actually get some definitive information
from some folks there I can't be sure
about that but it is a possibility also
you know we now do a better job of
correlating what we get from our
instruments with what is recorded in the
ground it used to be we needed the
geologists in the field to tell us what
happened on the fault and in fact the
details we get more details by walking
down that fault than we'll ever get from
an instrument we now we have over many
years of recording them and comparing
them we have a guess that that magnitude
six point four is partially a statement
of how much slit happen
how much once I mean with respect
together and at that magnitude with this
fault length that's on the order it's
under a meter but but a half a meter a
from either two so one a couple feet so
it's a pretty potentially a pretty big
offset the questions whether it's
confined at depth of whether it made it
up to the surface and there have been
hypotheses that if it comes to the
surface you get a different shaking
pattern than if it doesn't and not all
of not everyone agrees with that
hypothesis and so it'd be really that's
an interesting piece of scientific
testing that can go on because of it
what's your knowledge of this vault in
terms of how deep it is
false most false it's what we don't
write literally if it is because we
don't even know what faulted us yet
right if it is the little lake fault
that fault is mapped at the surface that
means that some previous earthquake it
has come through to the surface and most
earthquakes begin about five to ten
miles below the surface it's difficult
to get a big earthquake to start up
close to the surface there's not enough
confining pressure by the way if a fault
could open up you can't have an
earthquake right because the earthquake
is shaking just like snapping your
fingers try snapping your fingers when
they've opened up you don't make a sound
right and that's if the fault opens up
he wouldn't be producing any shaking and
at the surface
you know there's it's not as confined so
the earthquakes happen deeper down so
most faults in California extend at
least from the if we map it at the
surface it probably goes at least ten
miles down and probably more than that
and it just as it gets deeper down there
behaves differently there's a lot of
ancient volcanic history not so but the
but little egg is a volcanic region
there are some active volcanic right oh
yeah well and the China like weapons
center runs into a thermal plant there
so there are active there's active
there's there's magma at depth there's
melt molten rock at depth which has been
used to tap for geothermal energy so
it's a potentially volcanic area
you're 9% 9 in over the next week and if
we get if we get through a day then
we'll be a lot lower
it's not like it's not an even thing
over the week the most likely time is
right now as we see actually okay
the rate of aftershocks is substantially
lower now than it was in the first
briefing right so thinks these things do
die off really quickly with time any
other questions
wrap it up let's at two o'clock we'll
come back and see if we have some more
just super quickly sorry you mentioned
the trail leg Naval Weapons Station and
you've been saying damage is probably
highest in the Ridgid crashed in China
Lake area are you hearing the baby
damage at that Naval Weapons Station
remember Dunwich does not get reported
to us we had a phone call with OES who
the only thing they told us was about
the structure fires in Ridgecrest okay
and I heard about a water main break in
San Bernardino any idea if that's
related it could be it improbable but it
must if it did it was already in bad
shape
No yeah no okay